- Welcome back, y'all.
You know our next guest from
a number of popular shows.
She's also a very
talented singer and writer
who also happens to have a new book out.
It's called "Seasons of You,"
and it's out November 14th.
Please welcome Kat Graham, everybody.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
I love your outfit.
- I love your outfit.
- You look so cool.
- Did you wear this for
me 'cause my name is Kat?
- You know what, I didn't plan that.
I didn't plan that.
- She did plan it.
- I did plan that.
I'm that, that would be
stalkerish. (laughing)
No, but you just got married.
Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- And it was quick, right?
Like you decided.
- We did a private thing.
- That's the best.
- We were gonna do a wedding
with family and friends next year,
but we just wanted to do something for us.
- Yeah.
- And we woke up and-
(audience oohing)
- Beautiful.
- There he is, shout-out
to Bryant Wood, my love.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience applauding)
- My love, I love it.
- Yeah.
- So I'm gonna switch gears here,
just because-
- Sure.
- I had no idea that about your career.
Like I knew about your career as a fan.
- Yeah.
- But I heard
that you like received
death threats and stuff,
which I found crazy.
- It's a lotta people don't know
that a lot of people
that are in the industry-
- I've received them.
- Yeah, everyone does.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, not everyone, maybe
some people are fortunate
that they don't have that,
but even this week, you know.
I get them,
you know, sometimes.
- Yeah.
- Regularly, but I think any time
that you are about any sort
of empowerment or freedom
or, you know, self-acceptance,
and you represent any
marginalized community
or you're just different and
you speak up for yourself,
then that's just something that kinda goes
with the territory.
So it doesn't bother me,
because I look out and I
see girls that look like me
and people that might have the same idea
about human rights that I do,
and I know that they might
not have the privilege
to sit on your couch and talk about it.
So I have to.
- Yeah.
- So it's worth everything
that comes with it, for sure.
- Absolutely, no, I do feel there is
(audience applauding)
like a bit of responsibility
with that, yeah.
- Yeah, for sure.
- I do feel that.
- For sure.
- Did any of this tie in to your new book?
It's right, it's "Seasons of You," right?
- Yeah, it's right there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So can I show you?
- Yes, you can.
We wanted to like, buy this,
like yeah.
(Audience laughing)
We were like,
- Oh, well, sure.
- We were like, yeah.
- Sure, but yeah, so I
talk about like the fact
that we all go through different seasons,
and there's so many moments.
- I love that it looks
like a secret garden.
Like I love it.
- Yeah, well,
this actually comes off, in case you-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Don't wanna deal
with my face.
(Kelly laughing)
There, this is actually
what the book likes like.
- Yeah.
- So I'm really happy about it
and it's, you know, I designed a little,
a keyhole, so the-
- That's so cool.
- The key to your, you
know, what you go through.
But there's certain things I talked about.
I talk about my personal life.
I talked about things
that I've gone through
in the industry.
I talked about really everything.
It's the most I've ever talked
about my personal journey ever.
- Yeah.
- Which is something.
- Which is hard to do,
to be that vulnerable, yeah.
- It's hard to do,
and I'm also a big guarded, you know?
I come across pretty open,
but I do keep a lotta
things close to my chest.
But when I was approached to write a book,
which I really thought I was just going
to be writing (laughing)
just a daily to-do journal.
- Yeah.
- Triple Virgo
was thrilled with that.
(audience laughing)
That sounds great.
- Do it.
- Let's just do that.
- Yeah.
- Let's just do that, but then
it winded up becoming this,
which I fought the entire way
through making this book.
I did not want to talk about the things
that I've gone through-
- Yeah.
- Or necessarily do that but-
- But I think
that might help people.
- But that was the thing
that made me say, okay,
well let me create something
that I feel like is gonna help people
so that we understand that
when there's heartbreak
and when there's loss
and when you're having a moment
where you feel totally empowered and-
- Yeah.
- You have tools
to be able to navigate that.
When you're feeling creative,
when new changes are happening,
when you wanna reflect,
when you wanna reorganize.
Like all of these moments
that happen in our life,
they happen sometimes when
we're not expecting them.
And we so often are
blindsided by these moments
that you thought wouldn't happen,
and then they happen.
- Yeah.
- And you don't necessarily
have the tools at your disposal
to navigate them.
- Yeah, 'cause I think
what's important about that too is
that I discovered therapy
over the last few years,
and a lotta people can't afford it.
It's expensive, right?
- Yeah.
- So it's kinda cool that
you do something like this,
'cause all the tools that
you've learned in life,
you can, exactly.
- I put in there.
And I'm pretty honest about everything.
And obviously, everyone
has a different way
to kind of get to your best self.
- Yeah.
- But this is stuff
that I've used that might be helpful
for anyone of you guys, so.
- I love that.
I think everybody, we all
wanna be the better versions
of ourselves.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Your mother was supposed
to be a part of the book, right?
- Yeah, so again, which is,
it was at one point, I was
actually not even going
to come on the show 'cause I was,
I just lost my mom.
(audience sighing)
And I was like,
well, there's an opportunity here
to talk about her and to honor her.
- Yeah.
- Being here.
And she was originally supposed to-
(audience sighing)
That's my mommy.
- [Kelly] Aw.
- And she was originally
supposed to do the closing
of the book.
But she unfortunately got too sick,
and she couldn't do it.
And what it taught me was
that, through our work as artists,
and through our work as people,
we can continue the legacy.
And it can be legacy for
people that are still alive.
It can be your children
or your friends or it can
be people that you've lost,
people that have passed on.
And you can use whatever you've learned
as a way to continue-
- Keep them alive.
- To keep them alive.
- Yeah.
- So at the end of the book, now,
there is a part where I
kinda turn to you guys
and I ask you guys to kind of break down
what you've learned from
like your season of fall,
which would be like the
season that you've lost.
Or like your summer,
your summer that you felt super empowered
and all of those things.
So at the end of the book,
you reflect on those things.
And that's the way that
you kinda continue that on
and you-
- Yeah.
- And you, yeah.
So, you know-
- I love that.
- I hope I honored her
and I definitely talked
about her strength and as
much as I could, right?
- Yeah.
- I hope I did good
by you, Mommy, I hope you're-
- Yeah.
Oh my.
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
- I hope you're happy.
- Whoa.
- I don't want that, I want this.
(Kat laughing)
Let's do
another commercial break, y'all.
Kat's book is called "Seasons of You."
It's out November 14th,
but everybody here is getting a copy.
(audience cheering)